hey this is Ken McIlroy's company is
called MC companies ken McIlroy's
business is in the business of acquiring
assets
that's why his company gets richer and
richer and richer every year he adds
probably a thousand new apartment units
to his inventory so Ken's company gets
richer and richer because MC company is
designed to increase assets poorly
designed businesses never have any
assets they have huge liabilities ken
macro s business gets stronger and
stronger and stronger because every year
she's increasing more assets the Rich
Dad company gets stronger and stronger
and stronger because every year we add
more assets this year we're adding
franchising to our mix we're also you
know rich brother rich sister the book
has come out we come out the real book
of real estate eccentric cetera and
every one of those products every year
continues to send money and that's an
idea of a well-designed business as I
don't care it's for real estate or
making a cash flow boardgames if it's
well designed investors will give money
to you because this is a well designed
business I think the big mistake is I
hear so many people say it's important
to save that's ridiculous and the reason
that's ridiculous is because what
happened in 1971 is crucial in 1971 the
US dollar stop being money in 1971 the
US dollar became a currency when the
president took us off the gold standard
what's happening is all the savers today
on losers the problem with 1971 is that
the federal government keeps printing
money so the value of your money keeps
going down so a very big problem for
most people to stop using the word save
and use the word hedge you've got to
hedge your money hedge against losses
when I buy a stock I put a hedge and I
put a stop loss or a put inside of it or
this has happened throughout history it
happened thousands of years ago with the
Romans with the Greeks with the Germans
with the English the Japanese and the
Chinese every time they've made money
into a currency something you could
print and unlimited every time that has
happened the currency has gone to his
true value which is zero you just
watched two amazing clips of Robert
Kiyosaki take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]